things are quieter in this warehouse
than they once were it's been a hard
year if you work in haulage the problems
now stacking up
diesel and petrol hitting record highs
hurts everyone who drives it cripples
those who do it for a living
steve's run this firm for four decades
between staff shortages and now this he
says he's never seen it worse
well he's about 148 gallons of pump so
yeah that's that's painful very painful
to give you an idea the truck we're
sitting in does eight miles to the
gallon
so it drinks a lot of fuel um it's our
second biggest overhead after our
staffing costs and that's about 25
percent of our costs and it must be
passed on
and bypassed on he means ultimately to
the consumer a crisis of costs hitting
not just directly at the pump but
indirectly too
and while the drivers are diverse it's
being made worse by the threat of
conflict on the other side of the
continent oil is
likely to go probably higher still
there's a lot of tension obviously
between
russia and ukraine and that causes a lot
of turmoil on the oil market
and so there's a fear over a shortage of
supply should things escalate there
the context is that fuel prices were
already hugely inflated pushed up by
this big boom in demand after the
pandemic these latest tensions will
entrench those trends and likely extend
them yet more pressure on a general
public who already say they can't cope
with much more
and the strain is showing across the
economy british and european stock
markets were all down today preempting
future problems
markets don't like volatility they don't
like uncertainties if you think of how
the pandemic affected the supply chain
we're still feeling the effects of all
those snarl-ups well if there are
hold-ups because of increased tensions
because of issues with russia then those
price increases that we're already
seeing coming through i'm afraid they're
going to increase even more
no matter how hard you plan or preempt
there seems no let up to this cost of
living squeeze
ukraine may seem a world away from here
the impacts of what's happening there
are not
helenan smith sky news slow